today's topic i thought we would do
something a little bit different to that
there's often a lot of talk about
privilege
you know who's got the best privilege et
cetera et cetera i thought we'd make a
tier ranking
list ranking the best to worst
privileges
okay now if you guys want to
play along or make your own tier ranking
of this i'll put a link in the
description since i took some time to
make it
so here's i kind of set it up i said s
tier which is recruit difficulty okay
this honestly just makes life so much
easier okay then we got
uh easy mode which is a tier b tier
which is normal mode
c tier which is hard mode and then d
tier which is
impossible mode okay well your colors
are all [ __ ] up why is that
well because impossible mode i would put
it on red not green
but whatever hey listen you know what
you're right i'm just saying you're
right
you are 100 correct but that's what
we're gonna do this is my first tier
ranking yeah i mean
i'm just saying yeah yeah yeah but but
yeah okay cool you did good
i don't know wait till i see the photos
where do you see the photos no no no no
no you got this
look i know this look all right
before any of you get triggered oh you
don't know my life like how are you
gonna just say it's israel i'm not
saying it's easier or hard you may
you may be a white person who grew up in
a trailer like i don't know maybe who
knows
i don't know your life i'm just saying
on the essence of being just this one
thing
does it make it easier or harder that's
it and you know there's some disabled
people who are living their best lives
you know
so it's like it varies but i rank it
like this
if i had to choose between a or b which
one would i choose and why
if i choose this one because i feel like
it would give me a leg up in some ways
then i rank it higher it's easier right
that's it
disabled privilege oh green
green impossible mode that's hard and
i'm not saying that
there's a lot of people that a lot of
people some people that have
disabilities that they
drive and they do this [ __ ] they do
everything they got to do and
nothing can stop them out there all the
way up but i mean
in in terms of well they're all the way
sitting down but so
they like makes me think about it your
tattoos are [ __ ] sick that's like
sick
the dyed hair is sick you have like a
very like greek
goddess type face like it's sick put
your legs
but yeah it's hard it's harder like
you're going to live your life
but the minute that someone doesn't
think about oh yeah
stairs you're [ __ ] you can't go in
that in that restaurant or some [ __ ]
like that someone has to carry
it's it's yeah i put it on impossible
all right we both agree on impossible
mode
all right black privilege well i got a
photo of rachel dolezal oh
you no that's frank rachel she trains
rachel you know i mean she was black for
many many years with her curly hair
where are you putting rachel doing the
black
c c heart mode yeah yeah you think it's
on the bottom
the black thing yeah yeah see see yeah
white when i see because i'd rather be
black
and have able body than white and
disabled
that's my way of thinking i could be
white i'm
like [ __ ] what's his name the
scientist stephen hawking
i'm still good have you asked me this
question 40 years ago
i would agree with you today with upward
mobility and options i'm not saying it's
not hard
i'm saying it's a lot easier i'd rather
be black yeah
i agree so that's why i put out i put
out a normal one i don't think it's
great i don't think it's absolutely
terrible i think most days it's pretty
decent
what be black yeah i mean it's
definitely
being trans and being black black light
skin privilege i had a sami shows a
picture
we put light skin privilege light skin
easy mode easy mode eight year eight
year yeah
well i'm not saying that you don't face
anything but eight year
you know people if you saw oh you're
excited you know i mean they view some
way yeah that's a [ __ ] because your
people don't necessarily consider you
your people
why people don't consider you people
because now you're not but
all in all i believe that it would you
still got some pretty good privileges
so and the way the beauty standards work
yeah i've seen some pretty ugly
light-skinned people passes pretty just
because of the color of the skin
that's how they would say in in the
society yeah i mean you got places where
skin bleaching is a big thing yeah where
people are desperate
because it comes with privileges exactly
oh you got that good skin you got that
fair skin
yeah yeah you might know drake things
like that easy mode yeah easy mode yeah
yeah
i want to know drake i know people are
not going to be happy i am a fan i don't
care
i don't care make your own tear okay
2021 big booty privilege where you
putting that
oh i'm going s
yeah i'm going s yeah you can be as fit
as you want girl
you got that booty though you got that
booty get on it cuz that buddy
it doesn't even matter if you fit or not
yeah if you got a booty that nice booty
it's a mute
it's not her booty it's not a beauty i
could change everything it's a booty
from rags to riches yep yes from booty
shorts to
the booty shorts
speaking of financial privilege
financial privilege
easy i'll put a s here right through
difficulty
yeah just a bunch of agreements i don't
even think i agreed
yeah i agree you know what it's like to
be have debt agreed poor
i've not known
no getting money just when you see
people starting to get money you see the
way they're thinking change
they really are very much more yeah not
me
but most people are very much more
uh right-leaning
i went from democrat to republican you
know on one paycheck
i said the government's ticket how much
who needs health care [ __ ]
before i'm this should change a lot so
you put it at ester
yeah but you know money's not everything
no it's not
it's but it's a lot it's 90 it's it's a
lot there's a lot
it's a lot yeah well rich people commit
yeah and
poor people way more don't don't you
just don't hear about it because they're
poor nobody cares nobody cares so don't
act like people you know
all right here we go beauty privilege
ass yes let's go s if there was a w on
top of s i would put it
like you see you see how it finishes
here okay i'll put it
here well how about this we can put it
towards like the top so like you can do
the order by which you think it's best
even among s privileges
i put money before money money and then
beauty yeah
booty [ __ ]
you can't say this i know i'm leaving
that in it
two-parent household privilege
hmm me person i'm putting that on a
i'll put it down because i wouldn't put
on s for one reason because you could
have some shitty parents yeah you could
have some pretty shitty brands but even
by the numbers like yo the advantages of
having two parents
wait days straight yeah
all the single parent household my mom
was no she wasn't she was your mom and
she was a very great mom
but she wasn't both dark skinned
privilege
put that at c because it's not the worst
worst
thing but it's not great you know in
brazil they don't even allow like
dark-skinned people on television
listen there was a queen for the
carnival in rio
one year and she was dark-skinned they
lost their [ __ ]
yeah they lost their mind yeah
geographical
privilege meaning where you were born
your passport that's a
i'll go a step above i'm gonna put an s
here actually
i can understand because if you're
making a country that can
bro i got family in different countries
who have the shitty passports they can't
go anywhere
without getting extra visas and going
through a bunch of procedures people
don't recognize the
privilege of being having access to an
american or a kid oh i agree
until i travel to places even my even by
some of my cousins in the states yeah
they're like man i wish we was raising
scandals sometimes yeah
we wouldn't be in the trouble that we
would be now
yeah i'm like let's go with that
because trust me i'd rather have this
above a lot of stuff all right white
privilege
what do you put on my privilege i'm
putting it at
putting out a tier
eightier and my reason for putting it at
atx for as long as i've grown up
whiteness whiteness has kind of been the
default as great as like being the
default is in most
places and as great as your perception
of whiteness is when you travel to other
countries when you go to asia how they
view you and they worship
white folks a lot not even low s
not even low s because these are the
things i would put out if you ask
if you ask me this me personally would
you rather be a handsome black man
or an ugly white person i'm choosing a
handsome black man well i'm already a
handsome black man so
if you rather be a rich rich minority or
a poor white person the rich mine
already
eighth year you want to be in a great
country as a minority with a great
passport or in a shitty white country
where they got shitty passports
you made your point right so my thing is
more so like um
low a high mid a mid a i still put being
in great shape above it i probably put
i remember was on t ring up mid mid mid
time
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no i
get it yeah it makes sense rather be
dark skinned or a white person it's like
here's the thing i'm not saying what do
you want to be it's more so like which
one do you think is going to lead to
better outcomes
yeah exactly that's not a question of me
it's a question of yeah
i'm good with that i'm good when i am
but if you ask me objectively
i'm
so that's why i probably put it there i
think white brothers everyone always
talks about that one but i'm like it was
a bunch of other ones i would pick
being able-bodied able-bodied that's
ester
it's there ester able-bodied ass here
straight to the top
yeah all the way up the able body is not
even a
it's s or d yes
able bodies top tier in my opinion what
else does that yeah you could achieve a
whole bunch of [ __ ]
being disabled i understand that but
it's top tier
top tier ask a bunch of people with all
the money in the world
when they choose all the money in the
world or lose both their likes
if you have to even think about it it's
s-tier
do you feel what i'm saying so that's my
thing another one yeah there's a whole
bunch of ones i think are way better so
i
just think it's such a focus on
whiteness but that's just me personally
okay here's a controversial one iq
privilege
i'm gonna put it at s i'm gonna tell you
why taking conservation at your iq i
mean like
academic you acid that's a big part of
your childhood
and because it's a big part of your
childhood it's a big part of how you
build your self-esteem
and if if if you ace every test you got
and you're doing good
you have more chances now i know it can
come with some pressure that's not what
i'm talking about
you have more chances it can still be
shitty because your parents they put a
whole lot of pressure on you
but technically if all of that and you
make it after college
because of your iq and you're having a
better job it comes with other
privileges
automatically so i would actually put it
in esteer i agree
i agree with you on that assessment and
for me for different reasons one of the
biggest predictors of success in life
is iq and i would put in terms of like
upward mobility and stuff
iq is one of the biggest that along with
any conscientiousness but yeah
you know people with low iq the outlook
on life is not great no
you know it's akin to being disabled in
some situations and i know people don't
like hearing that but i'm talking about
pretty low iq most of you don't fall but
then again i would actually put
iq higher than money because most of the
time
if you have high q it doesn't
automatically come with money
but you have more chances of making
money i'm gonna disagree okay
go ahead i'd rather if i'm in a poor
country for example i'd rather have
money than iq
fair i agree right i agree that's facts
i agree you know in terms of and
we're just talking about not like the
happiest i'm talking about the easiest
because in a poor country
yeah i high iq might get you killed
they want to keep the people poor and
dumb shout out my people in haiti that's
what they try to do in haiti in the 70s
all the people that had education had to
flee the country yeah
they had to leave because they were
getting they were they were getting x
off yeah right everybody that had
education and i could get the education
it's not only that you have to have the
money but you have to have the academic
academics and iq to stay in school and
they try to x them off
so cool this is a weird one i don't know
how you feel about this one food
privilege what do you mean
what is that healthy food privilege oh
yeah
no that's a big thing that's estier
that's true
um yes because it affects the whole rest
of your body like
the whole rest of your body and how you
live
big or small i've seen i got some
friends they pretty big
by society standards they fat but they
were around healthy food so they good
yeah their arteries are not they good
their arteries are not they big big yeah
big chicks
arteries are not cl uh knock logs
they're doing good they're doing great
they're not at risk for like
they're not at risk for for diabetes or
whatever what not because they
they were around some good food around
them whereas i seen some kidney people
that they were living in the hood they
have mcdonald's mcdonald's
mcdonald's there's their 35 high blood
pressure high blood pressure
they have they chop off one of their
foot like they did contacting
like you know what i mean just because
of the location so it kind of goes
with geography privilege within
your country right yeah indian native
american privilege
d d oh no
that's you put it in c i said d d
impossible i said d
okay you are very well versed in this so
i'm gonna let you go
because right there and then it comes
with a whole lot of baggage
when you're native american it comes
with a whole baggage of the family and
the what they did to your family and
everything and stuff
but it comes with the geography like you
can't it comes with that
you're talking about some native
reserves where they don't have access to
clean water clean water in canada
in the states today okay so it comes
with our access of water
it comes with poor services sometimes it
comes with yeah they don't pay taxes
but they put they seclude them some kind
like on the reserve and if you try to
get out of the reserve
and get an address on a normal land you
lose your privilege of not paying taxes
your your reparation is gone so they
want to keep you there yeah but
speak on the historical aspect because i
think it's really important let's be
honest specifically
in canada up until there you go 1996.
that's yesterday up until 1996 they
would kidnap
in the indigenous kid and he would put
them in schools
and basically those schools boarding
schools and ways those schools were
doing
it was to erase the indian in the child
and it was an actual
saying that they had it's not me trying
to do some marketing
that's what they try to do they tried to
erase erase the indian
in the child okay so they couldn't
practice none of their uh
religion they couldn't practice all the
rituals they couldn't speak the language
they couldn't conversate with other
people in their language
they cut their hair just because they
did the same thing they did black people
cut their hair because they didn't want
to you know affiliate and stuff like
that so you couldn't have long hair you
couldn't speak your language
you couldn't nothing you couldn't wear
your attire
that had pry with you they want to turn
you white basically didn't discover
a masquerade recently listen they went
to these
old sites of all these boarding schools
these residential schools i'm sorry
these residential school that they had
and they went there and they start
digging and they found remains of
kids how many i think we like right now
we're at the 1
500 that they found that they found that
were just 1
500 right that they found
that they just um like that 1500 kids
like that
and they're still counting because as we
speak right now they're still digging
and doing recoveries of other they
didn't discover them
they're recovering them let's be honest
with them that's something that was
happening before and that you know the
catholics were doing
with with with the natives that's what
that's what happened so you have all of
that
you have all of that and what happened
what was happening the treatment that
was happening in those schools was
horrible
the life expectancy when they would
kidnap you and you would get into a
school
your life expectancy you had 61
chances of dying i don't know what kind
of school that is
61 chances of dying
in that school within two years so it
was pretty bad and after that
uh those those kids when they when the
the
the remaining kids that are survivors so
now all the native americans that you
have
in canada that are right now are
basically
either the kids of the pierce people
that went
like their grandfathers went
grandparents went to that school or
their parents
went to those schools with all those
traumas without any help without any
mental help
with anything so they're just left like
that with all their trauma to
just be an adult they were weinstein
they were epstein
all these teens and we just left them
like that to just go on
so you go like that and you get
kidnapped with a bunch of people that
you know from your reserve
and then you live through that and you
see them die the same thing as
an a soldier basically and now these
people are living with all that
that trauma so yeah with all that
baggage i put an indeed
just the fact that black people had to
overcome all everything that we overcame
and we're still at the point we have
dealing with our [ __ ] and it happened
segregation stopped in 65 and we're
still doing
we're still dealing with the [ __ ] that
we're doing the joyful and stuff like
that the native american
in canada the native americans dealt
with that
in 96 until 96 so it's still not
all right next up we got male privilege
b b go for it why no i just
put it in a i put a a i put it at a not
b
i put out a hey you want to play a
cause cause i'd rather be a man and a
woman damn right
and yet there's some problems with being
a man would you rather get you'll be the
[ __ ]
there's some man that bottoms
true so i'm just talking about the
general
you know for most of us we know what it
is but anyway at the end of the day
i'm just saying hey listen hey do you
want to bleed once a month or not
do you want to carry a baby for nine
months or just be like maybe it's gonna
be okay
maybe i hope so
you damn right i'm not saying that women
don't have supreme advantages which is
why i put them on b
tier which is normal mode but if i have
to choose between the two
i would choose being a man yeah that's
what i said i put
more maybe yeah that's why i've like
will want to say that yo i want free
tampons i'm like yeah you should
uh yeah i'm not bleeding once a month
that's a you problem they damn well
should birth control
don't let me get like a politician to
get and rule this country there's a lot
of thing that
kind of changes people are pissed off
about but all right so i think we can
reach the end here
pretty much got to the end wait do we
say white privilege that's good
yeah that was good it was good it was
good it was good next time we do food
we can do food food around the world
brazil right to the bottom
poland right to the bottom like
pierogies
brazil with pierogies brazil brazil i
like pierogies but i mean
is it ester it's not st is it even
deteriorating brazil
brazil you got good barbecue but
everybody barbecues yup
there's a bunch of that going straight
to the bottom and there's a couple
everybody's going to be offended that
they go into the bottom oh yeah
um the way my mom and nobody cares about
your mom
okay we got to be objective and if it
has to be your mom that proves the point
because she does it differently
therefore she is the exception but i am
right so that's my
we definitely if you want to see us do
that video let us know in the comments
and again
this video is not to be like your life
was easy or your life was hard it's just
recognizing the advantages
right being tall being tall is being
better better than being short this is
an exercise that everybody should do
this this is something that like makes
you think about your own privilege
even if you're not in the what is top
privilege for you
it's a good conversation to have it's
good to know it's part of you know
the self-awareness program you have to
be self-aware of what you
have and what you don't have it doesn't
make you better than everybody
it just makes you shittier than people
it's just is what it is
that's it that's right if you
acknowledge that there's downsides to
being ugly that means you recognize as a
privilege
and being beautiful if you acknowledge
that there's a downside of being poor
you acknowledge this privilege with
being rich
that's all there is no it's not to be
like you rich people need to slap flash
it's not that we're just
we're having fun okay so just take take
the stick up here out of your ass we're
having a good time we're just chatting
it's just it's just a video it's not a
dick don't think it's hard but anyways
if you guys want to try it it's in the
link
below all right go check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
is
fit privilege fit privilege easy money
easy mo cause right away right from the
bot right right from the
they get the start people are gonna
assume that you are healthy
people are going to assume that you're
healthy that you're good looking and
everything and stuff
even though you take a whole lot of
things in your body to enhance all that
and it's not going to show well i'm
going to say this i'ma put fit at normal
because the maintenance and the work
that goes into actually having to
maintain it
it's not something that you get and you
keep it's something that you have to
constantly upkeep
whereas if i was to take something like
uh
light skin privilege you got it or you
don't okay you know so i wouldn't put on
the same part go
i understand what you're saying let's
say
do you think that you have to do some
kind of work to upkeep the money that
you have
does the money that you have bring your
privilege we're not we're just talking
about the privilege here
not the work that it has one again it
gets you so yeah
it gets you have to have work you know
what i mean like i have to maintain my
hair and [ __ ] like that or i choose not
to
but it doesn't matter you know what you
know what i'm gonna give it to you on
that point
first privilege oh my god
right here in the bottom left okay
that's trans privilege
where would you rate trans privilege
right now you're just making
calculations all right what can i say
and get away with
well no matter what i say i'm not going
to get away with okay
so um
it depends it depends it it means a lot
of factors
that's just one out of many if just
transness just trans privilege yes i
identify as an intersectional feminist
okay so i recognize that black people
exist
i'm a good person okay where do we put
it right if really dave jennis was
watching
where would you rank her privilege
c c seek here you think it's hard mode
yeah i think it's hard no
okay yeah i think it's really hard yeah
yeah yeah you not being in your body not
feeling your body and stuff like that
okay if you're mentally if you have to
choose between trans women
and trans man are you gonna rank them at
the same level
no lgbtq2ia privilege
um
normal mode normal mode no no yeah in
this day and age being gay
gay people i'm talking about success and
i'm talking about america i'm not
talking about i'm talking about the
americas
you know what i mean i'm talking west
you know but you know i'm not talking
about that i mean all righty boy
so i am not afraid you know what i mean
you are in some countries well i will
put it at easy mode
i think um and the reason why i would
put that easy mode you know in terms of
like the game and stuff
is because because you can shut the [ __ ]
up about it
what do you mean she shut the [ __ ] up
about it shut the [ __ ] up about it my
black people don't know yes
that's true yeah i mean but
if you think about it like especially
gay men gay men are hyper successful
it's crazy how overrepresented they are
and like successful tears yeah now they
still face some levels of discrimination
but i mean if you're in the gay village
they're kings so i'mma put them in easy
mode
even in the media yay you can't talk
about yay pause
so